all right so why don't we um begin the
afternoon session
um it's a pleasure to have i think it
says ravi kanan here but dressed up as
edo liberty
so ido was kind enough to make it from
sfo and will be joining us
this afternoon giving a talk on simple
and
deterministic matrix gestures
thanks
thanks so yeah
sorry for uh i for some reason thought
my talk was on wednesday i apologize
and for anybody who came to listen to
ravi and you get me i apologize
um okay so let's kick it off
so i don't i think i don't need to sell
the idea of data being a very large
matrix to the audience here
so it's not always the case but it's
very often the case
and this is true for many different
kinds of data this is true for
text and audio and video maps in uh
certain manifestations
uh user actions and recommendation
engine data
um and and so on
um and here i just well here i just
plotted down
a few sizes of matrices that i sometimes
see in yahoo
yours might be different but it doesn't
really matter the idea is to just get
a feeling for the scale of the problem
so we will think about these
data matrices is having is being like
very long and
and fat or very short and fat
uh where each column would be an in an
object or an event or or some
measurement and we'll have many of those
so we'll have many more columns than
rows
and we'll think about the matrix being d
by n
and n being significantly larger than d
okay
so obviously the data is way bigger to
store
way too big to store on one machine
and often the situation is even worse
the situation is the data is
streaming and again i don't need to sell
the idea to this crowd
but just think about spam detection
where you
don't want to analyze all of the history
of
emails ever received by yahoo to train
the
current classifier just want to update
something and be ready right away
and the same thing happens for example
when you call the web when you have
some little uh some little piece of code
that just sees
tens of thousands or millions of
documents of text and has
very you know very limited amount of
space it needs to somehow process text
in a very efficient way but
it cannot store everything so you just
see
one column of this matrix at a time
so the question is what can we do in the
streaming model where we get
one column at a time and i just give
here the
the obvious task to compute the
covariance
so this is just a times a transpose this
is a d by d matrix
and of course we can compute it in the
streaming way this is just the sum of
the outer products of the column so i
take every column i multiply it
externally with itself i get a d by d
matrix and i just sum those up
this gives me an n times this square
operations
algorithm and of this square time and we
get the covariance matrix exactly but
even this very simple task is impossible
when d is large so think about d
being roughly a million which is a very
low resolution image in today's
standouts or
a pretty you know uh document in a
limited dictionary
so that's 10 to the 12 operations for
any column update and
roughly one terabyte of space so
you even computing the covariance is
already prohibited
so again
many people in this crowd kind of
invented this entire notion of sketching
matrices
and the idea is that we want to process
the matrix a
efficiently get some concise
representation of it in any way that
you know i'm not committing what concise
or efficient is yet
and we want to somehow get another
matrix such that either a is roughly
like b
or a a transpose is roughly like b b
transpose
and again roughly like i also mean i say
it
intentionally vape because different
sketches give you different things
but then if you if b is a faithful
enough representation of a you can do
many different things that we want to do
like pca signal denoising classification
of different things
clustering if you use spectral
you know dimension reduction techniques
for that uh
approximate matrix matrix multiplication
reconstruction recommendation so on
okay so this was uh
and this is just a big slide saying that
of course
this is an active area so
the results that uh talk about column
substitute selection so i just want to
choose a subset of my columns maybe
re-weight them
and we have pretty recent results by uh
trini acetal uh
giving almost with almost matching lower
bounds
there are uh specification results uh
they just
basically take the matrix and just try
to sample specific
entries and not complete rows or columns
and again there is a paper there is a
pretty recent result that i think is
almost getting to be tight but i mean
almost there are uh subspace embedding
techniques
that culminate in clarkson woodward
2013 they got the best stock paper the
best paper let's talk for this
uh it's not here on the in the table and
i'm going to present
a third result that that adaptively
sketches the
matrix so you get columns and you
somehow do something adductively
and so liberty 13 is is this paper that
i'm going to talk about
and there's gp 13 this is the last row
this
is uh gashami and phillips in utah
university actually
improved on my result or basically show
that the same algorithm
also gives you better guarantees or
other guarantees that i did not prove
so let's dive in
all right so what we what uh what we
will show is that there is a
an efficient algorithm efficient way to
save a matrix b that has only
two times two over epsilon columns
such that a a transpose minus bb
transpose is a very small
two norm it's actually smaller than uh
epsilon times the frobenius norm of f
square and the forbidden snow of f
square is just there as a
normalization factor so i want this to
be scaling variant with f i mean
we can set epsilon to be whatever we
want later
and what we're going to do is we're
going to extend the
the michigan grace algorithm or the
frequent items algorithm
and i'm joking that and i say it was
it's an algorithm so good it was
invented four times but it is a really
fantastic algorithm and it was it really
was published four times i'm sure it was
invented many more than four times so
but it's it's a simple algorithm with a
fantastic idea behind it so i actually
want to describe it for two reasons a
to show it to you because i i think it's
neat if you don't know it and
and two because the proof is actually
going to be almost identical
so the the task is a frequency
estimation of items in a stream
and we're going to see a very long is
this a laser
okay but it's too small anyway okay so
we're going to see a very long list a
stream of
items here are represented by colors by
the end of the we're gonna we're gonna
have
d different possible colors
and by the end of the stream i'm going
to ask you how many times have you seen
the color purple
and maybe you've seen it five times so
that would be the frequency of
of the color purple in your stream and
of course
we can do this very easily by just
keeping a counter for every color that
we have so if we have all of this space
it's trivial to do this we just keep a
counter and we add one every time we see
a color
that's uh but of course we want to do
something better we don't have this
space think about a little router seeing
ip addresses and after a month
of operation i come to it and ask how
many times have you seen iphs1
you know one two nine one six seven so
on
um or think about the front end machine
that sees
uh that sees search queries and you
wanna say how many times have you send
query x you don't want to save all the
queries in the history
so the mishra agrees algorithm i'm going
to if if you know it by the way i'm
going to
actually describe a very very weird
version of it but again it's weird
because i want it to
match the the other algorithm
so we can fix we're going to fix l
counters we're going to
decide what l is later and i'm going to
uh
keep the keep the counter such that at
least one of them is always set to zero
okay so i when i don't have if any if
any counter is set to zero i can kind of
ignore it or throw it away
okay so uh when i get an item i have a
count of four i add one to it
and when i get a counter that i when i
even when i get an item that i
don't have a counter for it i create one
for it but now
i don't have less than l counters so i
need to delete some of them or somehow
make more space
okay and the way i do it is i look at
the median
counter this is in this case two
and i just delete two from everybody
just remove the counters by two if you
had less than two in your counter then
it goes to zero and you just are deleted
from the sketch and then you continue
okay by the end of the stream what you
have is approximate frequencies
so the uh the approximate frequency you
will report for green in this case is
one
and four purple is zero because you have
nothing for it okay
so let me actually let me prove this to
you
that this works this is the entire proof
again this is not to torment you but
just because the other proof is
kind of the same so i can hand wave
more aggressively later i can kind of
gloss over more details
so uh first of all uh
so we want to show that the frequency
the approximate frequency and the real
frequency are not off by more than
epsilon n
from each other the way to show it is at
first the
approximate frequency is lower than the
real frequency because you add one but
you sometimes delete things
but it's also larger than the real
frequency minus the sum of deletions so
in the worst case you were unfortunate
enough to always have been hit with
those deletions in full
so this is at most how much you deleted
so we want to somehow bound this sum of
delta t
and we do this by saying hey the sum of
my approximate counts by the end of this
process is positive it's greater than
zero
but i can also count it in a different
way i will just sum up
all time steps every time every
time step i add one and then i delete
something
and what i delete is at least l over two
those are the things
greater than the median this is the
bigger half
and then for those i delete at least
delta t
so so this is i deleted at least this
much and if i push the
sum inside i just get n minus l over 2
the sum of delta t
and if i arrange this side and this side
i just get the sum of the l that is
smaller than twice n over l
and then if i just set l to be 2 over
epsilon i get i get what i want
okay so this is the entire proof okay
if my intuition of the the algorithm is
actually that
what happens is that every time you
delete okay you have this phenomena that
each specific counter is only hit
by a fraction epsilon uh of what you hit
the entire collection of counters okay
so you are uh guaranteed and
and this you cannot do uh very often so
if you do this
uh too often you run out of counters
okay so what's what's happening so how
are we going to convert this to matrices
so we're going to have
this uh matrix with at most l columns
and we're going to keep that some of the
columns are always set to zero
in the same way we did for the counters
now we're going to maintain that some of
the columns are always empty the same
thing we did for the counters when we
get columns we just
put them in the sketch until the sketch
is full so now i have l columns i need
to make some space for new columns
okay the way i do it is the following
first of all i compute the svd of this
sketch so
bear in mind this is d by l so it's
l might be 100 or something so it's it's
a pretty it's very slim
right so computing the svd of this thing
is not so horrible
i hope um
and i rotate the so b
is i can write this u times s times v
transpose this is the svd decomposition
of
of b and then i replace b by b nu which
is just u times
s i kind of nullify the right rotation
okay
so what do i get by that
well we have that b b transpose is the
same thing as b
nu b new transpose because i just i i
just remove the
right hand side rotation so the
covariance matrix doesn't change so i
don't lose anything
okay they would be like rearranging the
terms of the count so kind of
shuffling your accounts which doesn't
change them
and we have this property that now my
sketch is such that
my its columns are orthogonal and
decreasing in magnitude
okay and i kind of uh show it by making
the
rectangles bigger it's not really bigger
but i mean the norm of this first column
is largest
okay but now they kind of look like the
counters from before
so i just look at the two norm square of
the median column
and i remove this this energy from
everybody if your energy was lower if
you're to the right of this media and
you just get nullified and now we have
more space
and we continue this is this is the
entire algorithm
so if you wanna if you're into
algorithms then
you have it written right here but it's
exactly what i just said
um how am i on time by the way
good okay so let's go through the so um
the entire proof of this algorithm is
three slides i will try to build
uh brief with it so if i look at
uh so we want to bound a h transpose
minus b b transpose this is a difference
covariance this would be like
looking at the maximal difference
between two different counts
okay uh then i i kind of it from the
left by a test vector
x so this is the same thing as this
thing
and now i write the two norm of x times
a is just the sum of dot products with
the test vector this is the sum over n
the the columns and here i just uh
write it as a uh this is a this is the
sketch at time t
and this is a sketch at time time t
minus one so these cancel each other and
we get just
zero in the beginning and t in the in
the sketch in the end of the process by
the end of
it um and now
this thing so this is uh x times
a the norm of that in x times b
t minus one that's the sketch in time t
minus one that's exactly the two number
of my
the vectors that i added and the sketch
from before but it's
exactly like um
um this is exactly
so i didn't define c okay
so i sees uh c is in the in the
algorithm so
c is is the sketch before the shrink
step
okay so this is exactly the same thing
as just adding the vector to the sketch
but before the shrinking
so you get this thing and now i can look
at the shrinking step
and say uh so again so i have i can
rearrange this as the sum of this
difference in covariance matrices but
these i can show
are smaller than sum of delta t because
this is just the
shrink step i mean i somehow make sure
to always uh
somehow shrink a shrink the matrix
uniformly so this
is so this is bounded by delta t
okay and again if you take x to be if x
is a unit vector which is
what it is then you just get uh that the
difference in covalent is the smallest
sum of the
it's is it most sum of delta t
so now we have to bound the the other
direction
um you know let me just not go
through through this but this is uh
let me just go through the intuition
instead of of of dragging it
so in if before we had that the sum of
counters was positive here i can say
that the frobenius norm of the resulting
sketch is positive
okay this is always true or non-negative
okay i can
i just sum it up and as it as a
as this telescope sum okay so these
cancel each other out
and then i can add this extra term this
is the c matrix this is the sketch
before the shrinking step in every in
every step
and again if you just rearrange the
terms you get that this is smaller than
the forbidden norm of the original
matrix minus l over two times some of
delta t
and again if i just rearrange these
terms i get this thing
and if we recap we get that
uh the difference between the covariance
matrices at most some delta t some of
that is smaller than this thing
so if i just set l to be two over
epsilon
then uh i get what i want okay
and i write here that the two proofs are
surprising or maybe
unsurprisingly very similar but
i want to say that this is very
unsurprising i mean it's
it's basically the same algorithm
slightly extended
so i want to i want to say something
i will say some something about
extensions of this but let me just show
you some
results uh this actually this plot when
i saw it was uh when i decided this is
actually worth publishing i didn't it
didn't
i thought it was like too simple of an
idea but
then when i saw this i decided maybe
people should know about this
so so i took a matrix with
linearly decaying singular values and
added gaussian noise to all the nonzero
to all the matrix
and then i tried to uh
compute a a transpose minus bb transpose
given
b being different sketches okay and i
used
three simple techniques uh
naive just returns zero every time so
b is just returning an l by
d zero matrix sampling is uh
sampling columns by their l2 norm square
we know it's not the optimal thing we
actually know it's probably the wrong
thing to do but still it's
simple and quite often used hashing
is uh is one of the algorithms
in actually we've seen it in many places
but it was analyzing it was it
received a new analysis in uh clarkson
woodhof in
2013. so this is hashing
uh columns with random signs to
a collection of l you know placeholders
and random projection is just
multiplying the big matrix by a big
random projection matrix
a gaussian
okay so i don't know if you can see this
so obviously so
and sorry uh on the x-axis i give the
number of columns in the sketch on the
y-axis the accuracy obviously
the more columns you take the more
accurate you're going to be
uh so we see that uh naive
uh so we see that sampling hashing and
random projections on this data actually
produce exactly this or roughly the same
thing
i know this is uh probably not true for
all data set but for this
experiment they were surprisingly they
they actually perform worse than just
returning a zero matrix
okay this happens because you unbiased
things so if you sample things with very
small probability
you have to divide by the probability
and then you end up blowing things by
too much
so if you under sample you'd rather you
know you are better off not doing
anything
but of course they become better than
not doing anything
this blue curve or bluish curve is the
theoretical upper bound of
frequent directions and the yellow
curve is actually is the is this
algorithm
and this light up this light blue with
the
square ticks is uh is svd this is brute
force so in this
this is the one you cannot do right but
it's the
theoretical orbit
okay so yeah i should have normalized it
but uh
so i think it was
so i think it was one thousand by ten
thousand
because i had to run svd okay i'll show
you a bigger matrix in a second but
i just i wanted to be able to run svd
for the entire so i
this is like 200 singular vectors of
this matrix
and the running time okay so what
happens with the running time you
ever the algorithm adds these columns
but then one every
l over two steps it runs an svd this svd
takes d times
l square so amortize it ends up being
something
like n times d times l so it's linear in
all three of those
and we see this uh the running time is
indeed linear in all three uh
uh parameters but just
to point out that this uh point here
this is a hundred thousand by ten
thousand
dense matrix sketched out with
a hundred uh l equals one hundred so a
hundred columns in the sketch
which is roughly this uh
this point here it's not bad maybe or
maybe not good enough but
that's what it is and this takes uh 180
seconds this is three minutes it's not
bad
okay brute force is svd
it's just is
you mean which package you mean which
software package or just
which algorithm it's three this is so
this
is uh let's say 130 top singular
values of the matrix singular vectors of
the matrix are the sketch
which are the thing we know minimizes
this
yeah yeah i mean this is an offline it's
a theoretical lower band we cannot
really run this of course this is not
one of the competitors
right no it's actually columns this
internal svd rotation is actually mixing
them in some weird way so
you theoretically are kind of battling
this thing
okay so the running time is is i think
for most
purposes is uh is not bad maybe not
optimal
but i want to add some things that
happened uh
after i i wrote this paper so first of
all gashamin phillips
i want to say something about the result
they showed that actually if you
let me see where i can say this in the
most
no this is not going to help
okay so they show that if you take the
number of columns
to be something like k over epsilon
instead of two over epsilon
what you get is a rank a
approximation result meaning that
if you take the sketch you take the top
case singular vectors of
that okay and you project your matrix on
on those vectors
then what you get is uh
an approximation whose residual uh or
the forbiddenist norm of the residual is
one plus
epsilon what you could get with svd okay
so this is a one perception
approximation the best k approximation
of the matrix
um
this uh i think is uh it's definitely
worth reading i think this paper should
be out soon
another thing that i want to say is that
those sketches
end up turn out to be uh infinitely
combinable so if you have
20 parts of your matrix you can sketch
them in different places and then it
takes the sketches kind of stick them
next to each other and sketch it again
with the same algorithm
and you don't me and you don't lose
anything so the same guarantees hold
and the last thing i want to say is that
it seems to be this again from
discussions
uh with jeff phillips and he talked to
uh
david woodruff a lot i it i i'm almost
certain that this
algorithm gives uh the best trade-off
i mean it matches the lower bound
between space and
accuracy so if you want to uh
if you are allotted some amount of space
and you want to get the best accuracy
this is the best algorithm to use
but then it's not the best in running
time so
we know actually that hashing techniques
are significantly faster
so there is still room uh to improve
this so
i mean the hashing techniques are known
to be not space optimal and
and this is not known not to be running
time optimal
and that's it i think
i think that's it i mean i'm just
clicking to the end because just to make
sure i don't have any more slides yes
any other questions
um okay so the the question was
and tell me if i'm uh butchering it
but what happened so he says uh
in the in the boundaries that i have
there's like you measure the two norm
between the covariances but you
you you measure it in epsilon times the
frobenius gnome
whereas in the counters you have uh
some l infinity norm type which is the
maximal deviation between the two counts
right
and um the
and an l1 type which is the sum of all
uh
frequencies and i actually want to say
that the
it looks like l1 things for the counters
but
they're also actually they're actually
also l2s because
when you think about counting items
you actually counting uh
you're actually counting um
you know zero people kind of
encountering zero one vectors like
or standard basis vectors right and for
those the l two norm or
and the l1 norm are the same so we so
let's say this if you take if you run
this algorithm on a matrix that
encodes items so instead of item i i
will just give you the standard i
basis vector then what you will be
running is exactly frequent items
okay so in the end you will have
frequent items kind of
result you can just read the the
resulting matrix out as
as the accounts so it looks like l1 but
it's also
l2 i hope i
hope let's answer your question
no so okay there are a lot of things
that i know could make things better so
you can remove the factor to approximate
so there is 2 over l
you can make it 1 over l very easily
right so and that's no and you can do it
without running
hurting runtime but you can i'm sure
also do something
approximately in a way that probably
doesn't hurt things but i have i mean i
didn't look at it at all
you